so in this video I'm gonna show you
actually show you how to Rockefeller
family make billions of dollars using
they're rolodex by the way if you're in
your 20s you've probably never seen the
rolodex before but this is what they use
for many many years
today's rolodex doesn't look like that
today's rolodex looks like this
however the context and the power of a
good rolodex has not changed in this
episode I want to talk to you about ten
different types of context you won't
have any rolodex the quality the context
you currently have and action items on
what to do with your current rolodex
[Music]
so before I get into today's content if
anything you think about prompts a
question or thought comment below and if
you haven't yet subscribed to the
channel please do so let me get right
into a look the Rockefeller family the
Kennedys the Vanderbilts all of these
last names there are some habits that
passed down generationally from the
grandfather to the son to the grandson
and it continues to go down these are
habits the Rockefellers are known for
business right but john d rockefeller
son john d rockefeller jr. had his son
david rockefeller when he died recently
couple years ago he was worth 3.3
billion dollars he was known for having
mastered the art of networking I want to
show you what he did every time he met
somebody and I'm gonna show you exactly
what his three by five cards were at his
place at his home office that they had
their family office that that in that
suite he had a five foot a five foot
rolodex of 100,000 contacts it was a
total of 200,000 index cards three by
five with information on them let me
share with you some of these names on
what it said on there okay these are
some of the names you see let's look at
the white Eisenhower's as you look at
the 3x5 card it tells you his name how
did introduce some dear mr. president
his field
his background wife what part of the
country they lived in university they
went to the first time they met at
Carnegie Endowment for international
peace making the phone number the
contact information and other meetings
they've had in the past here's another
one you're looking at with Richard Nixon
the way he introduced and was dear dick
because that's how they spoke they met
first in nineteen
85 June 6th at a luncheon given by
United Republican Finance Commission for
for the state of New York
also Walter look at the details 10 1955
10 1856 this is way before Nixon became
a president here's another one for you
Donald J Trump Donald J Trump back on
first time they met it says they met on
9 23 1971 think about this the first
time you met Donald Trump he says maybe
I got to put this contact info side then
he puts when he got married when he got
divorced married to Marla maples you
know they met again 6 1879 at
Metropolitan real estate dinner and this
list goes down there's more context by
the way Henry Kissinger LBJ John F
Kennedy Mandela Bill Gates Gerald Ford
and the list goes on and on and on
what's the world the story imagine that
database imagine our rolodex 100,000
names what is a net worth of that
rolodex what is the influence of that
rolodex what kind of things can you get
done through that rolodex think about
the reach of the rolodex pink think
about David Rockefellers reach of his
rolodex meaning the value the amount of
contacts how much money they have how
much access to capital how international
it is the influence that they have just
by having that rolodex I will tell you
here that anybody I mean that's a
billionaire or somehow that estimated at
the highest level in politics they will
tell you the value of networking may be
above everything else in their eyes so
having said that let's get right into it
here's a few things I want you to be
thinking about different types of
contexts you cannot now this can get a
little bit more detail up to 30 of them
but I'm just simplifying for you one you
want to have access to people on your
rolodex that have access to capital
these are people that if you want to go
out and raise a hundred million dollars
five million dollars ten million dollars
two billion dollars you can do that my
access to capital with the context that
I have it's around 100 billion dollars
it wasn't like that 15 years ago it is
today number two access to legal counsel
different industries whether its
financial real estate marketing you know
you want it to be vast you don't want it
just to be general generalist good but
you want it to be specific third is
access to the right accountants tax laws
are changing regularly I don't think too
many times people just kind of look past
it oh it's okay I'll let my account take
care of it every year end of the I sit
down with my account he'll say here's
what's changing this is
what's going on over here this is what
this person is proposing if this person
gets elected locally this is what could
take place if this person you know votes
for this state here's what could happen
if this person votes for this on federal
law but this could happen and it allows
me to prepare for Nexus connectors
people that just know everybody I need
to get over somebody at the Dallas
Cowboys place yeah just call this person
boom okay great I need to get a hold of
somebody that's working with the
such-and-such organization I know
somebody called them over here you want
a lot of people here who are very good
at knowing everybody these are people
that always go to networking events
they're always at the bar meeting the
people they're great schmoozers you want
people like the nexus media whether it's
social media whether it's hard cast you
to whether it's a news media it doesn't
matter you want contacts in the media
because anytime you're trying to have a
splash or new launch or an announcement
you're making you can call your peers
and say hey I got this going on I want
to be able to launch you you talk to
them and say no problem I'll help you
out and then they're launched what you
have going on six is Intel folks who
have Intel research data inside scoop on
what's going on with a certain market
certain economy tell me about how this
event went tell me about how to South
without me you know South by Southwest
event was what's going on to New York
mark you tell me about the market in
Austin right now how's LA looking right
now you're getting inside scoop you want
people like that makes a sounding board
here's what I'm thinking about doing Jon
what do you think about this I don't
like the idea tell me why do I have any
blind spots am I missing something these
are good sounding boards to be talking
about Nexus celebrities because
celebrities isn't anything new no one
celebrity is a good thing because if all
of these major brands worldwide hire
celebrities hey they hire Shaq they hire
you know Messi they hire on a row now
there are all these people because they
have a draw they have a certain Q score
the same goes with you if you're putting
a party together gathering together
event together number nine is
politicians you want to know politicians
because eventually they're going to
dictate the laws so it's good to know
what's going on with your state locally
federal state all that level and the
last but not least is physically
attractive people this isn't anything
new you go to restaurants that have
attractive people people want to buy
from attractive people more than other
especially if the ticket item is higher
it's good to know people who know
attractive people whether you put a
party together company together
I run a sales office for ten years and I
had one thing that was a very important
thing for me I wanted good luck
men and women in my office because it
brought more people similar to a
nightclub except this is more business
but it still brought people to the
business so these are types of context
now you can set that aside and you can
have access to all these contexts and
you can still not have any value to it
because you don't have a quality
relationship with these contexts so
let's break these down number one if
you've made money together with somebody
that increases the level of relationship
you have with this person on your
rolodex because you call them and you
say Johnny last year we made 2.8 million
dollars this next one's looking it's
gonna be around three to four million
dollars you want to do something here
yeah how much you want to go on half a
million a million-two what do you want
to do I'm in for a million okay great so
you gamma send the information over to
you because we've made money together
there's credibility number two is we've
won together it could be sports it could
be in the past it could be we did
something together where we want
together there is that bond and trust to
know that I'm giving my best and you're
giving your best number three is
emotional bond emotional bond maybe we
shared a common loss together we had a
painful loss we had a painful moment or
you know we're connected through church
spiritually it doesn't matter there's
some sort of an emotional bond that you
have to each other so when you call for
a favor
that person is willing to help you out
because there's that emotional bond
number four is you had fun together you
travel together you played sports
together I don't know you went to you
know a concert together you go to
sporting events together you're laughing
with each you go to comedy shows
concerts together there's that emotional
bond of fun
you call that person that person is
willing to establish stronger
relationship with you so they'll help ya
this next one's interesting a common
enemy or an ally you may have somebody
that is an enemy of yours that's also an
enemy of mine you given me the contact
it's going to help us both win against
the competitor that we have or an ally
that we have six overcome something
tough together you had a startup it was
very difficult it was about to go out of
business and both of you guys were
really working hard and you helped it go
together and then and ended up winning
but that moment brought a bond and last
but not least as mutual friends or
family hey Johnny I was given your name
and number by a good friend of mine and
good friend of yours Bobby
oh yeah Bobby Bobby told me to call you
I got a business thing going on he said
you'd be a good guy to contact oh yeah
he told me you were gonna be calling
thanks for calling me mutual friends so
10 types of contacts quality to contact
and last but not least is action of
items on what to do with your context
number one most people don't take the
time out and go through their contacts
to see who's in here I got I don't know
I got eleven thousand some eleven
thousand one hundred and twenty-nine
names on my phone but I'll tell you one
thing here they're not all the highest
level of context neither are yours
neither was I ten fifteen years ago
maybe I am today but I wasn't ten
fifteen years ago but the first thing
you got to do is extract the solid
contact out of your phone number one
bother we can do this on phone and email
that's number one number two organize
and categorize based on this or based on
whatever else you may want to do
industry professional celebrity media
law tax it doesn't matter organizing
categorize kind of like how they were
doing it with the Rockefellers number
three staying constant communication
with them regularly
they gotta be hearing from you except
not asking for favors so if you
constantly ask for favors they no longer
answer your phone calls because it's
always for favors can you do this for me
can you do that for me can you do this
for me and that person's eventually I'm
like you're just trying to get stuff out
of me listen and there's no relationship
here it's not in constant communication
for favors it's in constant
communication birthday wedding
anniversary help how can I help you is
everything going on how this what do you
think about this it's basic
communication Anna last but not least
trying to find to add new names to your
list constantly so make a list of a
hundred names right now for yourself and
write it and said I'd like to be friends
with this person that person this person
this person that person and work your
list start working on your list we're
gradually I you had you hit them on the
list here I got 92 more names to go 78
more names to go 63 more names to go I
can tell you right now the emails that I
have or the texts or calls that I have
what people today ten years ago they
were on the list that I was hoping for
them to finally get on this is because I
want her to play ball out of higher
level but if I don't put them on the
list and I don't take action they're not
gonna get on my list it's the same thing
you gotta be doing it and eventually one
day maybe they talk about your rolodex
and the context you have because if
presidents if Rockefeller Vanderbilt's
if Kennedys if these people value
networking and building a strong rolodex
maybe you ought to do the same as well
or take your game to the next level your
business to the next level having said
that
two other videos I want you to watch one
of them has to do with how to network
like Casanova it's a very detailed video
about how you can become a better
network and obviously that has a lot to
do with this video and the other video
is how to measure your actual network
again how to measure your net worth
which is a very different approach I
take in this formula than what you
typically see online so having said that
comments thoughts please comment below
and if you haven't subscribed to the
channel click on the button right here
to subscribe thanks for watching
everybody
take care bye bye
[Music]